le chantier est énorme et occupé
ce sera une rivière d'un kilomètre
explique une des responsables du projet
elle se rendourie de parc de marais et
de terre humide restaurer
au plus facilement au lieu de déborder
vers les quartiers résidentiels du
Shannen Baker lorsqu'il sera achevé le
projet protégera 240 hectares de taille
hondables soit l'équivalent d'un
quartier qui s'étendrait de la Tour CN
jusqu'au centritel et ce à 20 minutes de
marche du centre-ville
[Musique]
appelle un exemple de classe mondiale
d'adaptation au changement climatique
les Portland construit sur un marais ont
toujours été vulnérable ou sinon à Sion
et ce risque augmente de jour en jour
le climat devient plus chaud plus
mouillé et plus extrême rappelle-t-il et
pas seulement à Toronto même dans les
scénarios plus optimistes les experts
climatiques prévoient que dans les
grandes villes du pays les jours de
chaleur extrême seront deux fois plus
fréquents au cours du 30 prochaines
années qu'il ne l'était entre 1976 et
2005 les villes sont elles prêtes pour
ces changements
Fiona vient ravager l'est du pays à
l'ouest l'an dernier la
Colombie-Britannique a connu la bague de
chaleur la plus meurtrière de son
histoire suivi des inondations les plus
coûteuses institut climatiques du Canada
prévoit que d'ici 2025 la moitié de la
croissance annuelle du Pays-Bas du pays
s'envolera en coulis au changement
climatique
du Royaume-Uni par exemple qu'ils ont
une politique d'adaptation nationale
depuis plus de 10 ans maintenant alors
que la nôtre arrive notre prochainement
l'automne je dirais qu'on n'est pas
nécessairement à l'avance en étant
Ottawa a promis de publier sa première
stratégie nationale d'ici janvier les
experts espèrent qu'il sera vite mis en
œuvre car les changements climatiques
auxquels elle nous prépare sont déjà en
cours ici bernadjukic Radio-Canada
toront